okay I have exactly 1 hour to do as much
studying as I can right now because I am
going to my sister's baby welcome it was
supposed to be a baby shower actually
okay so I just completed shortest bridge
on lead code I this is probably one of
my like more difficult ones the fact
that I can complete it and it handles
topics like DFS depth first search and
BFS breadth first search all inone
problem is astounding to me that I can
now solve such a problem it's been
literally about 8 days of me staying on
e code for 6 to 10 hours every single
day and this was one of the ones that
was on an orange and now it's on a green
and so I have how many problems I have
one I have 10 problems that I really
want to cram crank and into my head
before Monday these are 20 problems of
company specific lead code problems and
10 of them I feel I have down and good
the other 10 I need some more practice
with so I need to get dressing ready for
the baby shower I'm going to head
over and pray I can get back here by
like 6:00 so I can do 4 hours of
studying and 4 hours of studying should
get me through all 10 of these and then
tomorrow then it's just last finishing
steps I was in charge of creating a game
for the baby welcome and the stuff got
delivered so let me show you so the
theme
is like bees and like honey and
honeycomb so I decided to create a game
called sweet as honey which is basically
a taste
testing game I got different types of
Honey not really types of honey but I
guess like flavors of honey and I'm
going to put them all in different
containers for people to taste and
they're going to put in their guesses
for what flavor the honey is so this is
cinnamon whipped honey this is hot honey
oops it's extra hot that is a mistake I
did not mean it to be extra hot Orange
Blossom honey and based on who guesses
the most amount they get a prize which
is this BS bees cute little set the only
thing is babies can't eat honey or else
like they so I'm going to just let
everyone know like don't give the baby
Hy like it was going to feed the baby
honey but I'll put a sign that's like
this is for adult SL non bab consumption
only I was going to put them all in
these little glass containers but
look the way it got delivered
so that's
upsetting hello
[Music]
hello hi yes Nia I'm doing very well how
are you
yes so I started my career at Comcast
NBC Universal and my first rotation was
at DreamWorks it was a two-year
rotational program at DreamWorks I
worked primarily as a full stack
software engineer and when I came onto
the team I was actually the person with
the most web development experience so
very quickly on I was set to design code
and test a web app that would allow for
increased um
just autonomy to showrunners basically
my manager had to constantly keep tabs
of what storage looked like on the
different shows but now at this web app
the goal was for them to monitor that
themselves and my manager and the rest
of my team getting that time back so
that was my first year lots of learning
done there and then my second year I
worked as an iOS engineer and that team
was I was exfinity specifically um where
NBC Universal was the first year and
there I definitely learned very quickly
um how to learn even more rapidly than I
had had practice before because I for
the first time was working with mobile
apps so that was a huge learning
experience but I felt in love with the
development of mobile apps and so once
that was done I definitely continued on
um and trying to learn as much as I can
on the Swift side building mobile apps
and whatnot and overall that I feel like
is very interesting because being at
dreamers and working with imaginations
and creativity I found myself very um
excited to apply to this role given that
it's all about creativity and enhancing
Communication in that
way yeah I would say the example that
pops up um pops out at me the most is
when I identified basically a an
accessibility Gap Within in xin's um
products I very um
non-intentionally was in the meeting
with someone who was going over their
assets and products and I just brought
up um like hey I feel like the colors
specifically being used aren't very
accessible and after saying that I
actually took on to review a bunch of
the company's assets looking at okay if
a user needed to navigate solely from
the key keyboard would they be able to
do so if a user didn't have access to
viewing the image in front of the screen
how does the alt text read and things
like that and so by being able to
identify this I was actually then put on
a project that created a basically a
whole overhaul of the company's um
assets and looking at how can we as a
company do better what development um
needs to be done so that all images are
taken care of of and keyboard navigation
and even things like graphic design and
overall I was able to show that this was
a good investment because over 10% of
the United States population has some
sort of accessibility difficulty and
Comcast being a fortune 20 company at
least at the time they serve millions of
consumers and so 10% is not a small Gap
at all and they understood this and I
was able to make that difference
by then being able to provide a
step-by-step guideline on how to move
forward so
that people feel like the product are
made for them something that I found
very interesting was when decided to
overhaul their Android app because they
realize that Android users don't feel
like is made for them and there's a big
difference in um capability between
iPhone and Android users so being able
to do that for um a big market like that
in such a big way was very um powerful
empowering for
me it was on the web but also it was on
the assets that were also used on mobile
for example the digital assets the
images the text um colors things like
that were being used on
both it
was I don't have a true number of how
many assets what I can say it was
multi-level and multi-tiered for example
Not only would the images not be
accessible but also the um video assets
didn't have proper um like close
captioning and also keyboard um
navigation was not available and so it
honestly was at every a gap was
identified yes so so for example if a
person was on some page and they tried
to start navigating using either tab or
space bar or enter the keyboard the page
I remember at one point was able to
navigate through the main menu bar and
then jumped to the middle of the page
and then jumped back yes and so in order
to um provide a solution for this one of
the best ways I saw was by providing div
classes and IDs to spec really specify
this is an element that needs focusing
on when a presses on the tab overall I
feel like the interview went pretty well
you see that most of the questions I was
asked were accessibility project related
and that's honestly not even most it was
all of them past the initial question of
tell me about yourself and your
experience history all the questions I
got asked after that were based on my
accessibility project which I feel like
was a good thing this person was
obviously very um interested in it and
they ended the behavioral portion of the
interview stating that it would be
really great to have someone on the team
who is so accessibility minded because
that's an important thing for them but
it can be hard finding people who really
know the nuances it all inails so that
made me really happy then there was the
technical portion which wasn't um too
difficult at all I was actually very
surprised so I'm really happy about that
however I did make a small mistake while
implementing my solution I cated
everything out but kept coming up with
the wrong answer and the interviewer
ended up saying that it's very clear
that I know the answer and that I know
how to implement the solution however
it's probably that I'm very nervous
being that it is an interview space but
it's a very small minor mistake that I
am just I just keep missing and so that
was kind of annoying and I pray that
that is not cost me this entire job so
let's see but I have my fingers crossed
really this person saying like no it's
very clear that you know what's going on
but X Y and Z I feel like that's pretty
good um it gives me hope but again with
big companies and competitive companies
one little mistake can be what ends up
at all so hopefully that's not the case
but I will let y'all know but thank you
for watching these were a couple days of
my life as an unemployed software
engineer going through this job hunt
with y'all so let me know if you have
any questions in the comments below and
I'll talk to you all very soon